لا علاج له مميت وخطير وسريع الانتشار
نتحدث عن فيروس مارفل الذي يثير انتشاره
حاله من الفزع عالميا فهو يتسبب بحمى
نصفيه شديده العدوى بحسب مراكز السيطره
على الامراض الامريكيه سي دي سي وهو من
عائله فايروس بولا وكلاهما لديه القدره
على التسبب في معدلات وفيات عاليه بين
المصابين الصحه العالميه قالت ان معدلات
الوفيات من المصابين بفيروس مارفل تتراوح
بين 24 الى 88% وفقا لحالات الانتشار
السابقه واتعرف العلماء لاول مره على هذا
الفيروس عام 1967 عندما انتشر بين عمال
المختبرات في مارب وفرانكفورت بالمانيا
وفي بيل جراد اثناء اجراء البحوث على
حيوانات استوردت من كوغندا
ورغم ان هذا الفيروس لا ينتقل عبر الهواء
فانه ينتشر بسرعه من خلال الاتصال المباشر
بين البشر خاصه المرتبطين بالسوائل مثل
الدم او اللعاب او البول ويمكن حتى لجثه
المصابين ان تبقى معديه عند الدفع ووفقا
لمنظمه الصحه العالميه تقدر فتره الحضانه
للاصابه بالفيروس بين ثلاثه الى تسعه ايام
وتبدا اعراضه بالاصابه بصداع حاد ووعك
شديده والام عضليه تشمل ايضا حمى شديده
اسهال حاد والم في البطن وغثيان وتقيؤ
يمكن ان يدوم اسبوعا استمرار الاصابه تؤدي
الى اصابه الجهاز العصبي في الحالات
المميته وتحدث الوفاه في اليوم الثامن او
التاسع
يرى معظم المختصين ان الوقايه بشكل عام من
الحمى النزفيه
المرتبطه بالفيروسات مثل
قد تكون امرا صعبا اذا كنت تعيش في مناطق
تنتشر فيها هذه الامراض او تسافر لها
وعليك استخدام وسائل وقايه عند التعامل مع
اي من سوائل الجسم بارتداء قفازات وواقيات
العين والوجه كما يجب تجنب الحشرات خاصه
البعوض والقراض وعليك ارتداء السراويل
الطويله والاكمام الطويله واستخدام وسائل
الحمايه من البعوض كما عليك ابعاد القوارض
عن منزلك بوضع القمامه في حاويات مضاده
للقوارض والتخلص من النفايات بانتظام وحرص
على ان يكون للابواب والنوافذ وقيات حشرات
واذا كانت الوقايه صعبه فالعلاج لم يعتمد
بعد بل يعتمد ويتلقى المصابون الرعايه
الداعمه وعلاجات للمضاعفات والجفاف تعمل
على تحسين معدلات البقاء على قيد الحياه
وفق منظمه الصحه العالميه